hulu show this is so exciting
hey guys we are so excited to announce
that we have an
original series coming to hulu in 2021.
all right so what do you think is going
to happen in this on this show are you
like flipping tables
i was talking to your dad before and he
was like i kind of thought they would be
up in my face with the cameras but it's
very chill so how has it been filming so
far and are you ready to be a reality
television family
um it's it's definitely different than i
thought it was going to be just
because i'll be doing like normal things
or things that i think is normal and
they'll be videoing and i'm like how
could they make this interesting
like i feel like i feel like this is so
boring but then we got to watch
a few little previews of the episodes
and and it's really cool to see
our lives being portrayed in
a really honest way i mean it shows the
ups and the downs and the things that we
get to do every day no one really gets
to see the business side like
what was behind making this and now
people are and i think that that's so
exciting to be able to share with
everyone
do you think in a way people are going
to understand both of you and your
family
better i hope so i think what this show
is for
um is more for our supporters and our
fans not as much
the people i mean i would love for
people to understand us more but this
show is to show our fans and supporters
what we're doing every day to make
them happy and what we can do to make
them happy i love this
okay and do you have like the theme song
yet have you made it are you singing
it i don't know the theme song yet i
don't think we even have a title yet
yeah it's really as we're going we're
learning more about ourselves and
as a family and what it's like to even
have a
docu-series so it's like i don't know
it's
we're really go with the flow yeah
[Music]
let's unpack this life together we're so
excited because now we have cute clothes
to buy so i'm so excited for both of you
the promos are amazing and i know that
you've been kind of partnering and
working on this for a long time
so at what point did you realize in
addition to all my other things we want
to be clothing designers
my dad worked in the clothing business
his whole life we've always been around
it watching him create and
sell and design and everything and
that's what i wanted to go to college
for
and it just kind of i skipped a few
steps but
i'm doing what i wanted to do so i'm
very happy about that so the meaning
behind
social tourists is very cool can you
explain where the title came from
so social tourist is obviously very
fitting to us
because we do social media but it's also
about
self-discovery and finding who you are
because we're all a tourist to something
and we can all try new things and really
meet new people and figure out our
self-identity and i feel like that's
really what it's about and that's why
it's so exciting it's all about
everyone i love this and so the drops
are going to be different like every
time we get a drop
some of it is merch some of it is like
styled clothing can you explain that
so i think it's every four weeks um we
are going to be releasing a new line and
i'm so excited and each one like i want
the next one i want the next one
i just wanted to keep going i want
people to see everything but it's gonna
be really good i'm super excited about
it
what is the thing that you love that you
got to make that you can wear
with each of the drops you can
definitely really tell
who chose what it's very true to
ourselves her is a little bit more
edgy and darker where hers is like
pastel
neon cutesy girly this is like the spice
girls when i was young it was like what
spice girl you i'm ginger i'm baby it's
like i'm a dixie i'm a charlie and like
we can really tell
but the other thing is that there's some
things that might not be completely our
style but it's like i've seen so many
people wear this style of shirt or this
style of pant or jean or skirt whatever
it is
and it's like i know that they're gonna
love it because i know all my friends
love wearing that and it might not be my
thing
but someone's gonna look at that and be
like that's so me now you guys
both are so busy in hollywood i want to
know
a whose closet would you like to like
get into
like star power and then also you know
right now
you guys are young you're at the start
of your very long successful careers
who do you want to emulate like who do
you look at and you're like okay i think
i could
you know in 10 years i want to be ariana
in 10 years i want to be
beyonce like what what are those things
i would definitely love to see
jlo's closet just because i i just i
wish
you know but i feel like the great thing
about us and who we want to emulate is
like
we can obviously take little bits of
inspiration from everyone
but at the same time like we're figuring
it out and we're doing it for us
and how we want to do it and what we
like and that's what makes it so much
fun
you want to take jlo's closet because
she has the glitter you know what i mean
like
you are a dance competition kid she's
like fan kickstep platinum
like is it the showgirl like is that her
closet vibe i
i really think it is i mean when i saw
her in concert i was like i could
totally wear that for my solo next year
like you just want to be in costume
i just i really do i really do tell me
about
the future i read in the press release
this is a multi-year
deal so like how is the pressure of
every four weeks you have to like put in
new designs be ready to go
i don't see pressure i think it's more
fun i'm so excited i just want to keep
doing it and getting better and learning
and growing and
even though it's a little scary because
we have an audience while learning and
growing it's going to be
awesome i think our styles also change
very frequently so there's always new
pieces that we're looking for whether
it's a flared leg
or low rise or a high like it's always
changing
i got plenty of roommates even when i'm
alone
i've never known any silence i turned my
all right let's talk about music for a
second and what's coming and
this is moody yes i've been working
really hard these past couple months
i've been doing
writing camps and writing music and i'm
super excited to release i'm releasing
an ep this summer
um but yeah i feel like people don't
really know but i've done music my whole
life i've sang my whole life
theater choir everything so this isn't
just something i'm starting once i
started social media but i'm
starting to share it with people because
i'm more comfortable now which i'm
excited about i love that no you guys
grew up in the arts like you're a
theater kid so this makes
perfect sense dancing singing all of
these things
um i wanted to ask you the voice is on
right now
and so if you like you it's a big show
for our viewers if you could pick like
one of those people to mentor your
career there's nick jonas kelly clarkson
blake shelton
john legend like who's your who whose
team would you be on
well i know there's a new voice coach
for the next season ariana grande ariana
grande
i mean you're like i'm gonna pass on
this season but next next season
ariana grande obviously i don't really
give it
if you stay i don't really give a sh
you know i'm a big fan of your technical
dance skills obviously we all know that
she
crushes the tick tocks and the hips and
the drops and whatever they are but
but you really are a gorgeous trained
dancer is there anything in your future
that you're like i want to use that
more yeah i mean i have taken a step
back from dance just a little bit
because it's hard when you're in front
of a lot of people dance is not meant to
be perfect but that's what everyone
expects
but i'm getting back into it now trying
to do more improv because that's what
that's really what i love but i would
love to i was just in lil hadi's music
video
but that was really really fun it gave
me a comfortable space to be able to
dance so if i could do more stuff like
that i would really enjoy that
would you ever want to do broadway would
you ever want to join a company like
i mean when you're not busy like making
your own clothing lines and like you
know just being the most famous people
in the world
um i would love to honestly it's it's a
little bit difficult because when i
think of dance i think of my studio back
in connecticut and it's hard
to like not be dancing with them and
going to competitions with them but
hopefully
next year or maybe even the end of this
year i can compete again because that's
really what i love doing
you